hey crazies have you ever looked inside
a microwave oven and no I don't mean the
spot where your food goes I mean have
you ever looked at the electronics with
the casing off
no good don't it's super dangerous
but also the circuit is kinda genius so
let's talk about it it's incredibly
simple just a magnetron with its own
power supply a type of power supply
that's so inefficient it's almost never
used so how do microwaves get away with
it
[Music]
before we get started I'm a trained
professional I know how to work with
electricity without putting myself at
risk this isn't a mess around and find
out kind of situation do not try this at
home okay with that out of the way let's
get started this power supply design
only has three components a Transformer
a capacitor and a diode
seriously that's it
this combination of components has a
special name it's called a half wave
rectifier but I suppose not all of you
are familiar with this terminology
alternating current or AC is what you'd
get from a wall socket direct current or
DC is what you typically get from a
battery but sometimes you want DC
without having to worry about batteries
that's why we need rectifiers
rectifiers convert AC into DC but not
all rectifiers are created equal as the
name suggests this halfway rectifier is
at most 50 efficient realistically it's
more like 40 though
why even use it we normally don't but
microwave ovens are one of the few
exceptions
to understand why we need to go deeper
starting at the wall the Transformer is
the first step now this isn't just any
Transformer this thing is a beast it's a
beast a phone charger like this is your
typical everyday Transformer it takes
120 volts from the wall and turns it
into just a few volts so it can charge
your phone's battery that's why we call
it a Step Down Transformer it turns the
voltage down
the one in the microwave oven is a Step
up Transformer it turns the voltage up
that means it's extremely dangerous
it takes the 120 volts from the wall and
turns it into about 2 000 volts at least
that's the wave average and there's
nothing limiting the current which means
I can do this
don't mess with these things if the
microwave is plugged in unplugged
they're generally pretty safe though at
that point it's just a lump of mostly
iron and copper it's like a paperweight
it could still be risky though with that
capacitor in there which is also
potentially dangerous
it's got a big weapon resistor built in
to discharge it but resistors don't last
forever
if the resistor is burnt out that
capacitor could hold its charge for
longer than you might expect like for
years well not that long there's always
leakage the capacitor could still be
dangerous for several days though so the
safest option is for us to discharge
this before we go any further
nothing happened
no it just means the bleed resistor is
still good which means the microwave
still good
ambassadors store electric charge on
their metal plates and therefore they
store energy in the electric field
between those plates that energy can be
used for all sorts of things the
capacitor in the microwave oven is using
that energy for uh
well this might make the most sense if
we take some measurements but my ancient
multimeter is not going to cut it this
time we need an oscilloscope like this
one I got from keysight labs keysight
isn't a sponsor but in the interest of
full disclosure they did send this to me
for free frankly oscilloscopes are a bit
outside my budget so huge thanks to
Daniel bogdanov at keysight labs for
helping me out with this project
speaking of which let's get back to it
I want to take measurements inside the
microwave oven but just in case I was
forgetting something I asked a friend
for a second opinion
what are you doing don't you know what
happens if you put a probe in a
microwave oven with all its wires and
metal let's
test sure
I'm not wrong
maybe nothing
oh geez
yes see it will burn and melt your probe
it can damage your microwave oven and
it's a fire hazard too
foreign
I read your email wrong you wanted to
probe the gods inside the microwave oven
like the transformer not the
I've burned this for no reason still
this Transformer outputs over 2 000
volts ac that's so dangerous and to have
any voltage you would have to turn on
the microwave oven which means the
Megatron is also on radiating around and
if you accidentally touch the
Transformer output with the program or
your hand
see what I mean and worst of all the
scope input is rated for 150 volt RMS
not 2 000 volts and you don't want to
damage your precious scope so stop it
oh that was a close call
okay okay let's rethink this it's just a
halfway rectifier these things come in
all sizes how about we just create a low
voltage version and test that one with
the scope instead no it's not the same
exact circuit but it's going to be safer
for experiment clone and for the scope
his middle name might be danger but I
put a lot of work into experiment clone
I don't really want to have to start
over plus the waves we're gonna see are
gonna be roughly the same shape anyway
it doesn't really matter all we need is
a Step Down Transformer a capacitor a
diode and a dummy load resistor oh oh
and a breadboard to help keep things
organized we'll be using the Transformer
at all times
this will not only keep the voltage down
but will also keep the circuit isolated
from ground without it best case
scenario are breaker trips worst case
scenario we fry the scope the label on
our Transformer says 12 volts but we
measured it and it's actually closer to
15 volts always measure first
anyway we should be ready to hook things
up now let's start with the diode we'll
just slide that between the 15 volt
leads plug it into the wall and oh oh oh
oh oh oh boy
well that didn't work out the circuit is
what controls the currents and
apparently that was too much we'll also
need to keep the load resistor in there
at all times so our starting circuit
looks something more like this
you see the line that's moving up and
down
ah I do you want it on the line and just
move it up into the middle of the wave
there we go
the scope shows half the wave is missing
which is exactly what we'd expect for a
diode for comparison if we take the
diode out and just leave the resistor in
we get a full sine wave see a diode only
lets current flow through in One
Direction so all the negative Peaks just
end up wasted hence the name halfway
rectifier only the forward half of the
wave passes through how is that useful
it isn't we need to tweak it a little
as it stands the voltage is broken we
need something to smooth it out that's
where the capacitor comes in remember
how we said capacitors store energy in
their electric field that energy can be
used during the blocked half of the
cycle if you connect the capacitor in
parallel with the load it can charge
during the first half of the cycle when
the diode is allowing current to flow
when it's not allowing current to flow
from the source the charge on the
capacitor can still be released into the
load energy comes from the transformer
for the first half and from the
capacitor for the second half the
resulting wave is kind of interesting
and Incredibly useful
during the first half the capacitor
charges quickly during the second half
it discharges but slowly when it's time
for that capacitor to charge again it's
only given up some of what it had as the
cycle repeats you get a pattern that's
almost DC but a little ripply
that's why we call this a rectifier it
turns AC into at least roughly DC but is
this actually happening in the real
circuit
foreign
clone put the capacitor in backwards in
case you're wondering this is what the
capacitor looks like now don't make this
mistake learn from my experience if
you're using a polarized capacitor it
and the diode have to be pointed the
same direction once everything is hooked
up properly we get exactly what we'd
expect on the scope a roughly DC voltage
with ripple
I love it when the model matches reality
for practical reasons though we don't
usually use half wave rectifiers this
simple design still wastes over half the
energy from the wall
are you gonna make me ask ask what so
why do we use it in a microwave oh right
that that's where we started this whole
thing isn't it
this resistor represents the load the
actual device you're trying to power in
a microwave oven that's a magnetron but
if you look close enough you'll notice
something interesting
the magnetron isn't connected across the
capacitor it's connected across the
diode rather than the capacitor making
up for missing energy on the off cycle
it adds extra energy during the on cycle
this isn't being used as a halfway
rectifier it's what we call a half wave
doubler rather than Ripple DC we get the
entire wave from the Transformer but
there's something the scope isn't
showing us the wave is shifted it might
be a full cycle but it never actually
goes negative our circuit takes a wave
that goes from negative 2 700 volts to
positive 2700 volts and makes it go from
zero volts to 5400 volts it doubles the
peak voltage just by shifting it hence
half wave doubler but it's not a very
useful pattern unless you're a magnetron
having the voltage come in pulses is
perfect for generating microwaves in a
cavity but that's a topic for another
day of course nothing is perfect in real
life as many graciously explained to me
the load created by the magnetron is
going to counteract some of the shift
cutting a bit of the wave off and sure
enough hooking up our circuit just like
the oven gives us that sine wave but
this isn't that big of a deal if you're
just using the microwaves to cook food
you don't need it to be perfect you just
need it to work
so will you ever look at a microwave the
same way again please share in the
comments thanks to Medi from electroboom
for Consulting with me on this and for
the Cameo a special Thanks goes to my
patreon patrons and YouTube members like
Bosphorus who recently upgraded to the
Asylum counselor level thanks Bosphorus
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
I can't I can't help it it just happens
it's my crazy face
a lot of people were wondering why no
one talks about angular diameter
turnaround I'm honestly not sure I think
cosmologists see it as more of an
obstacle to overcome in their
observations like they're not trying to
hide it they just don't see it as
important anyway thanks for watching